when the military staged a coup in
february it cited electoral fraud as its
justification
leader aung san tsuchi and other top
officials were detained and charged with
offences ranging from breaching
coronavirus rules to corruption now
nearly 10 months after the coup the
junta has added election fraud to the
list
suchi's national league for democracy
had won last year's polls by a landslide
international observers have said the
elections were largely free and fair
political analysts and tsuchi supporters
say the charges against her have been
trumped up it has nothing to do with the
rule of law in myanmar
this church is just show tribe
um
it is prolonging of
military
ring of terror against people of myanmar
military authorities are holding aung
san tsuchi at an undisclosed location in
the capital nepador
the hearings against her have been
opaque
media members of the public are not
allowed to attend and the junta has
barred defense lawyers from speaking to
journalists
many analysts say the junta's intention
is to ensure she stays out of politics i
think if the military decides to release
her drop the charges or suspend the
sentence or whatever distortion of the
legal system they decide to do it will
be
with assurances that she won't play a
role in politics in myanmar in the
future
there have been sanctions against the
military and those associated with it as
well as calls from the international
community for the junta to release those
detained
but the military has so far resisted all
pressure a local group that provides
help to political prisoners says more
than a thousand two hundred and fifty
people have been killed by security
forces and more than ten thousand people
have been arrested since the coup
florence louis al jazeera